en 1943 winston churchill el famoso
famoso primer ministro donde la segunda
guerra mundial dijo una de las frases
que marcarían historia a palabras
entiende la gente pero amazon se queda
todo claro
una mentira la frase que dijo fue
la historia la escriben los vencedores
yo estoy yo estoy dispuesto a escribir a
escribirla esto en un contexto bastante
raro en ese entonces la población
británica sobre todo la de londres donde
vivía winston churchill vivian en
subsuelo o sea un equivalente al metro
y literalmente hasta en las vías de
hierro frío
por qué porque los nación estábamos
ardiendo la ciudad
técnicamente uno de los peores momentos
que había vivido en londres pero winston
churchill tipo tuvo el coraje y el
determinante para decir esa frase que
iba a escribir la historia porque le iba
a vencer
bueno pero como procuro en ese entonces
ni siquiera sabían que iba a ganar es
más los británicos estaban seguros de
que adolf hitler iba a ganar la guerra
pero la diferencia entre adolf hitler y
winston churchill es que winston
churchill si salía de historia un
ejemplo claro winston churchill bien
sabía de que históricamente la gran
bretaña eren era imbatible la unidad o
invadir los visigodos los sajones perdón
es de que un montón de bárbaros entonces
es como medio confuso napoleón mismo
link dentro invadir por poner a la
diferencia entre hitler y por ejemplo
napoleón es ninguna inapi hitler de
hecho intentó invadir alemán este rush
en invierno y almirón como les favorita
de manera mundial y calificó de
clasificaron
para esto algo interesante porque
winston churchill sabía de que la
historia era muy importante para la
gente del reino unido tiene que conocer
en el del pasado de la guerra que fue
realmente un error estúpido he tratado
de versalles el famoso peor tratado de
la historia jamás firmado bueno ese es
el tratado de guadalupe victoria la
verdad solo que los los gringos lo
admiten
no tienes debido a la referencia
y realmente fue un error británico
también tenía que conocer el antecedente
porque fruta dormir en una viga es
horrible una viga de tren imagínense
y también tenía que conocer cómo sacaban
cómo siguieron después de la destrucción
técnicamente de todo de todo londres es
curioso que este pensamiento de esta
reflexión le haya tenido uno de los
personajes más importantes de la
educación en méxico muchísimos años
antes de que siquiera nuestro chico es
el primer ministro y es nada más y nada
menos que josé josé vasconcelos
y que pulso la creación de la sep y que
en 1908 en medio porfiriato en una de
las etapas más oscuras de méxico entre
comillas
y dijo bueno sacó adelante una propuesta
para traer la educación humana
humanitaria es decir la las ciencias
sociales como la historia o la política
vaya en el porfiriato quien se atrevería
a hacer eso con porfirio díaz
técnicamente alguien y si lo logró
después de después después de la
revolución pero es curioso que hoy en
día no habíamos ese cambio no pero
ahorita en la actualidad las materias
más importantes son matemáticas español
tiene algunos casos ciencias
por qué pasó esto simple porque la
población mexicana no le importaba su
historia
es curioso que cuando les iba a
presentar esta presentación y tenía la
idea de darles una lista del por qué la
historia es importante pero me di cuenta
de algo horrible estaba repitiendo el
mismo discurso que me dio un profesor de
historia una vez y esto es un
pensamiento muy importante que lo olvidé
y alguien está presionado y aficionado a
la historia quién lo creería un error
que lo que pasó por no conocer mi propia
historia y una tomografía
ha cometido un error que cometió por
ejemplo donald trump con su propuesta de
traerles armas a los profesores para
resolver los tiroteos en las escuelas
y eso fue pensar que la misma solución
resolvería el mismo problema a pesar de
que histórica a pesar de que todos
sabemos de que no lo resuelve y si va a
ser en decirles oigan la historia es
importante en nuestra sociedad
búsquenla el primer error olvidarle es
obligar la historia es la debate de
cualquier de potencialización olvidar lo
que lo que nos trajo acá es la es común
es el estudio bueno es la razón por la
cual nos vamos a ir por la cual la gente
se nos va a olvidar para esto
eso es lo que les quería decir pero lo
que también estoy a decir es de que la
historia ese es el es el estudio del
constante de la constante la constante
evolución del pensamiento humano estoy
buscando las palabras y aparte tengo el
tiempo muy apretado entonces
y si nosotros tenemos este pensamiento
de que la historia son solo libros de
este grueso y si me tocó un libro de
este grueso y pesaba como un kilo y
después meto un libro que era de este
grueso y siempre lo llevaba en mi
bolsillo
bueno no los lleva en el bolsillo le
lleva siempre a la mano porque porque me
encanta la historia y es porque de hecho
la forma en que me gusta la historia no
es porque haya leído libros o porque
vaya museo así no es porque entren
porque siempre me gusta ver causas y
consecuencias me gusta de ver mucho cómo
llegamos hasta acá y eso lo que les
quiero decir en la historia no sólo no
es sólo una cosa no solo es un libro
sino también es
también son otras cosas están en esta
sociedad siempre hay una forma de ver la
historia por esto es muy importante
porque puede cambiar el mundo yo les
diría bueno estética bueno este lean
historia pero hagan esto pero no yo
diría saben que vean la vida por qué y
por qué la vida bueno la única forma en
que podemos ver la vida es mediante la
historia y la historia es el mejor mes
es el mejor nuestro muchas gracias